you guys probably remember this meme it
was very popular a while ago and and
this is this is what I mean that like
the story you tell about yourself and
about the things that happen to you um
isn't always one story so you in this
case you've got this idea of being a
data analyst and there's what my friends
think I do what my mom thinks I do what
my boss thinks i do my customers think i
do what i think i do and then what I
really do and part of the reason there
are so many different versions of this
one simple story is because you're
telling it differently to different
people right we all kind of present
ourselves a little bit differently to
our mothers than we do to our bosses
that we do you know to our friends etc
so you yourself as a storyteller have
the power to shape that data and it's
important to understand that you and
your viewpoints and what you're
interested in communicating are going to
be a powerful part of that conversation
and then related to that number three is
that you need to collaborate with your
audience right we saw in those six
different versions of the story part of
the reason they were different was not
just that you were telling a different
story but you were telling a different
story to each audience because of what
you wanted to communicate to them or
interact with them stephen sondheim's
says musicals are plays but the last
collaborator is your audience so you've
got to wait till the last collaborator
comes in before you can complete the
collaboration and the same is true for
data visualization and data science this
is one of the most important questions
you need to ask yourself I'm in any data
project who is the audience and I'll
give you a hint no matter what your
project is no matter if it's for an
internal team or for the general public
or first scientific journal your
audience is not you now why you know
this seems pretty obvious but a lot of
people write or design or engineer for
people who are just like them and the
chances of your audience being just like
you are slim to none and so you have to
go out you have to get critique you have
to test
and and I'll show you this just with a
simple civil illustration talking about
color um color is one of the most basic
building blocks or our choices we make
when we're communicating and but if I
and there's you know I don't know how
many people are in this room 20 30 if
there's just one color I have a swatch
of red here go ahead and tell me yell it
out what do you think that this means if
you just saw some red on
individualization or in a dashboard what
does I mean to you stop bad okay so
that's a pretty cultural norm that we
have here in other cultures you get
things like lucky good right it could be
a celebration red can be it can mean war
violence danger it can also mean love
celebration and money in some cultures
is tied to the color red so just one
color can be highly problematic and
highly regional now what if I had a
second color go ahead red and white what
do you got what's that okay maybe some
people see valentines day some people
see Christmas some color black okay all
right let's go to red white and blue
yeah patriotic whether it's French
American kabisa some people see there's
a lot of sailing flags semaphore flags
or in these colors okay what about this
one could be Italy could be Mexico could
be Christmas again and now if I change
white to yellow all kinds of things
right so just and this is just a color a
couple of colors in combination that we
haven't even applied them to shapes or
two graphs or to anything else and just
these colors and groups together in
proximity together you get all kinds of
different interpretations associations
connotations and colors again one of the
simplest building blocks we have and yet
there
so many different possible associations
and interpretations when when it comes
to applying color so i just wanted to
demonstrate that your audience is going
to bring all different kinds of things
to the table and some of them will be
obvious and some of them will not be
obvious and you make its really
interesting results really interesting
interpretations of your work and so you
need to put your work out there beta
test and show it to your colleagues show
it to your friends show it to your
grandmother show to whoever but get
feedback take critique and and
understand that you can't just hold up a
mirror and use that for your testing in
your design related to that John
Steinbeck makes an important point that
if the story is not about the hearer he
will not listen there needs to be some
relevance there needs to be a connection
to the audience you can't just get up
there and talk about yourself without
considering how the audience is going to
see themselves in that how they're going
to connect to that okay so I've
belabored that point a little bit but
think about your audience step 4 how to
data so people will listen see all the
possible stories I already kind of
talked about how there are multiple
possible stories depending on what you
decide to bring to the data depending on
what audience you're communicating with
and Jana Martella underscores this and
says the world isn't just the way it is
it is how we understand it no I didn't
understanding something we bring
something to it no but I want to get a
little deeper into this idea of many
possible stories because the data is
just the data and it's up to you how to
interpret it we've seen you know
competing versions of the same story
every day in the news you take something
polarizing like Julian Assange or like
pretty much any political football and
there are multiple interpretations of
the facts in terms of data visualization
this is one of my favorite examples this
is on the let's see your left is a data
visualization of the Affordable Care Act
what we know sometimes call it Obamacare
made by the the minority the joint
economics
um led by John Boehner so kind of
basically the Republicans and made that
one on the left the one on the right is
a visualization of the same exact data
made by an independent designer who
lives in California named Robert Palmer
so we understand from both
visualizations that this is a
complicated system but one
interpretation really aims to obfuscate
and to emphasize basically all you can
get from the one on the left all you can
really understand is that as complicated
really really complicated the one on the
right um while it doesn't necessarily a
shy away from that that complexity
definitely serves to try to reveal
something in that data rather than just
obfuscate so different interpretations
of the same facts Rebecca Solnit
describes us nicely when she says the
Stars we are given the constellations we
make that is to say stars exist in the
cosmos but constellations are the
imaginary lines we draw between them the
readings we give the sky the stories
that we tell so data works the same way
you have these data points and there are
the stars but the Lions you choose to
draw the stories you choose to tell are
really kind of subjective in a lot of
ways depending on who you are depending
on what you see in the story and
depending on who that audiences and so
the ability to see all the different
possible ways to connect the dots is
going to make you a much more
responsible storyteller but also much
more skilled storyteller so how can you
do this well you can ask other people
for what they see in it and again
feedback and critique are going to be
your friends here because there are many
many possible ways to draw these lines
and being prepared for all those
possible ways even if you have a
particular one you think is correct more
than the others and in order to be able
to argue for that and to make your case
you need to kind of understand what all
the different possible stories are um
and when it comes to data visualization
the the way that you draw these lines
can in some ways be really egregious
there's I'll go off in a small tangent
about 3d and why it's not your friend
if I were to ask you here which is
bigger the purple or the green this is
from a presentation that Steve Jobs gave
in 2008 and Steve Jobs did nothing by
accident so this is I think some people
call this marketing I call it propaganda
um but yeah basically he's using a trick
here it's in artistic terms we would
call this for shortening it's when you
create the illusion of 3d in a medium
that's really two dimensional I'm you
have to do this thing called for
shortening where you you make the
whatever's in back in this case on the
top visually recede by making it smaller
and you make what's in front visually
advance by making it larger so that's
why the green slice of the pie here
appears much larger and then you also
get this secondary effect where because
you're trying to create that third
dimension you're actually adding surface
area to the bottom to look like it's the
edge instead of the top but visually
your I interprets additional surface
area as additional impact an additional
import um and so unless you're actually
reading the numbers here if you're just
taking it at a glance you're going to be
misled but the stars the data points are
all presented here it's just the way in
which the constellation is drawn and
that's drawn in a misleading way so I'm
telling you this because I want you to
understand not just as people who create
data visualizations but as people who
consume them all the time you have to be
very aware of what the multiple possible
stories are the multiple possible ways
to draw the constellation and understand
what's happening there okay how did data
so people will listen opinionated is a
good thing and here's where I'm going to
get to python a little bit um if you're
using other languages like our like
JavaScript um each language kind of has
this one ring to rule them all situation
when it comes to visualization libraries
javascript has d3mr has ggplot and
python has in this room the right
answers bouquet but
i really know python has this
multi-headed Hydra situation where it's
got all these different libraries for
visualization that all do kind of
slightly different things a little bit
better and I think that's a wonderful
thing I didn't always think that's a
wonderful thing um but I was convinced
by Rob story who I don't know if he's
here but I i was actually convinced by
something he said in his talk at PI data
in May in Silicon Valley at Facebook his
talk was called up and down the Python
data and web visualization stack and he
made a pretty strong case he said that
you know I want to have more
visualization libraries out here I think
I've actually got it yeah we need more
visualization libraries and they should
be opinionated he said I'm not sure we
need another d3 library that can draw
line graphs but the more of his library
is the better and the reason is this
word opinionated that's the key right
because if you think about it a toolbox
all each tool in there is opinionated in
the sense that it does one thing really
well and it's designed for one singular
purpose and a tool box full of opinion
tools is going to beat a Swiss Army
knife designed to do everything well any
day of the week so you being opinionated
as the storyteller having a point of
view your audience being opinionated
having certain things that they bring to
the table and certain assumptions they
make the data of being opinionated and
you listening to you know the best
possible interpretation of that data and
your tools being opinionated and being
designed to do the job well when you
bring all these things together you're
going to be a very powerful and
effective storyteller and so this is
part of the reason i think python is
especially well suited to this kind of
pursuit of telling stories visually okay
how to data so people will listen final
point point six immerse yourself to
improve Lisa see said read a thousand
books and your words will flow like a
river I've never worked in banking but
I'm told that when you are hired as a
bank teller one of the skills you need
to have is the ability to detect
counterfeit bills
I'm told I don't know if this is true
but I really hope it is so great and
told that in order to train you how to
detect counterfeit bills instead of
showing you all the possible ways that
people could create counterfeit bills
they simply stick you in a room with a
lot of money and I always picture that
and who's the the McDuck character
Scrooge McDuck he's got this like room
this vault full of money that he
literally like swims in I just picture
that for every new bank teller hired
everywhere I really hope they do that
and but but the reason this story is
compelling for me is because it's the
idea that if you spend enough time
around the real stuff if you learn what
money smells like and feels like and
looks like maybe tastes like I don't
know but if you learn to instantly
recognize the real thing than anything
that's not that stands out there might
be millions of ways to create a
counterfeit but if it's not genuine
it'll stand out um again I don't know if
that's true but I love that idea because
I think you can do the same with good
communication with good stories I think
you can immerse yourself in in
successful communication and then
anything that's not that will stand out
and you'll slowly begin to understand
sort of what's effective and what's not
so I've made this part of my work when i
was at o'reilly for seven years and
working on their strata conference one
of the things i instituted there was
this data visualization showcase and i
spent months kind of going around
finding both well-known designers but
also up-and-coming designers unknown
designers and trying to find good work
good visualization and then bring those
to the conference so that people could
immerse themselves in good work in
successful communications and
interesting visual approaches and try to
put elegant and inspiring work in front
of people to help raise that awareness
and that data literacy about what's
possible and what good communication
looks like and you can do this for
yourself too um I kind of have to I I
would be yelled at if I didn't tell you
that I wrote a couple of books in order
to help people do this so beautiful
visualization is a collection of
basically 20 essays from different
designers
that I went out and said tell me how you
approach your work and what inspires you
and what work you do and I invited no
Italy in ski to come edit this with me
and then we we kind of said after we did
that book you know there's more here to
what's going on and so we we thought we
needed to add this second book to
conversation designing data
visualizations which talks about the
linear process of design that we go
through the series of questions that you
ask starting with kind of spatial
planning surface area and moving on
towards shape and color and typography
and all those other decisions that you
make and and we we argue very strongly
there that design is is not this like
airy-fairy creative process all the time
but that it can actually be a linear
decision making process and so it's
written to be very friendly to engineers
and programmers who are comforted by
that that linear thought process but I'm
kind of going to reverse myself in this
talk because storytelling the active
storytelling is not that linear all the
time we kind of think of stories as
having you know story has a beginning
middle and end and when we come to do
data visualization there's also
beginning in the middle and end we start
with data and then we do the
visualization we make the presentation
is done and I would argue that that
while there is a linear process buried
inside there that this idea of iteration
and of circling back around you you know
have you ever read the same book
multiple times several years apart it
just means something completely
different to you the second time you
read it or the third time at the fourth
time because you're bringing something
different to it as an audience member I
would argue that's why it's changing and
and so data is just like that it can
mean different things at different times
when you come back to it even if it's
the same information let alone if it's
if it's real time and it's been updated
because context matters and not only
your context is the audience but the
context of the world around you and so I
would argue that iteration is just as
important as this idea of a linear
process okay to sum up powder data so
people will listen use the power of
visualization
know yourself as a storyteller and what
you bring to the table collaborate with
your audience and respect what they
bring to the table see all the possible
stories understand the different
interpretations be prepared to argue for
the one you believe in but recognize
that that your version is not the only
version um but know that being
opinionated is a good thing both for
yourself for your audience and also for
your tools and finally immerse yourself
to improve immerse yourself in good work
seek it out ask questions and get
feedback all of that neil gaiman says we
owe it to each other to tell stories so
this this process is not optional and
with that I want to open it up to some
of that collaboration I would like to
take some questions and have some
discussion I'd love to hear what stories
you are trying to tell and what's hard
about them so don't be shy who's first
it's nine in the morning nobody's got
questions yeah and that's a good
question i was just at the strata in new
york and they did not have one there so
i don't know if they'll continue that or
not i I hope they will yeah
yeah that's a great point and that is I
mean it's called having a hypothesis
right that is the beginning of the
scientific method and so I think that's
a totally valid and a great point to
make yeah I think the thing to be
careful out there is just to make sure
you do have the feedback from smart
people in a room somewhere that you have
the disagreement and push back and and
to understand as you're looking at that
data not to just draw the constellations
that you already wanted to see right to
try to be as objective as you can and be
honest if the store you came in with
doesn't hold up yeah good point any
other comments questions war stories
yeah yeah there's a lot so data
journalism is a broad category and I
guess tools to do what would be my first
question
incorporating
so I'm sorry I'm still kind of not fully
understanding the question incorporating
all that Union all the different
visualizations into one view one page or
yeah yeah so I mean you can see the
Guardian has been working on doing this
the New York Times has been working and
doing this and I'd say those are the two
leaders in the field right now and it's
all going to be web-based I mean I
haven't really seen anything that's not
web-based so javascript is your friend
in that area although there are lots of
web-based Python tools that you can use
so yeah but most people just to be frank
with you are using d3 for that and and
other web tools there is a d3 pi
implementation so check that out if
you're really into python and and yeah
there are some other really good kind of
embeddable tools for that but it's it's
going to be web pretty much and in terms
of how to do that visually if you're
talking about lots of text on the screen
as well as visuals I would i like the
way the New York Times is doing it
because it's a lot of white space which
i think is important but yeah I would
say them in the guardian of the two
people really out there as examples
right now and I don't know what their
particular stocks are but I don't know
if that answers your question
yeah so um interactive data
visualization is complicated no matter
what but i would say you want to be
looking at like bouquet is really
powerful you want to look at d3 you want
to look at processing those kinds of
those kinds of tools yep other questions
no okay thank you